hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the most
interesting of all of these prima-facie
duties that Ross is talking about in
chapter 2 of the write and the good is
the duty of what he calls
self-improvement and this is one that my
students often can both identify with
and they also say oh wait yeah I didn't
I didn't think of that because they're
often in that groove where they they you
know feel like yeah I'm supposed to be
improving myself often they feel guilty
about the fact that they're they're not
measuring up to their own standards you
know every semester is going to be
better and they'll do all the homework
you know totally ahead of time and get
so much out of it I know what that's
like myself having been a student and
that doesn't work out that way but they
don't really think through why is it a
duty to improve myself and this kind of
goes against some some different ethical
you know notions that look so long as
you don't actually harm anybody else or
failing your duties to other other
people you can do whatever you want you
don't have to work on yourself except
insofar as not working on yourself makes
you count the kind of
- Mike you know rob banks or be a jerk
to other people or you know that's sort
of sort of failure Ross says no you
actually do have a duty to improve
yourself why he says it arises from the
same grounds as the duty of what he
calls beneficence misspelled veterus
okay one of the things I should probably
work on is spelling beneficence is doing
good to other people
hmm and we acknowledge this as a prima
facie duty as something that you know
there could be overriding circumstances
but in general if we can do good to
other people we ought to do good to
other people if we can make somebody
else's situation better with respect to
intrinsic goods or the things that allow
us to attain intrinsic goods then we we
should do so well you're somebody -
you're a person as a matter of fact if
you want to think about where you can
get the biggest bang for your buck and
let's say we're putting aside wealth
differentials or things like that you
know obviously if you do micro lending
you know for five bucks you can help
somebody start a small business in the
third world that your money can go a
very long way but you don't have control
over that so much as you do over what
you do with yourself other people can
give you all sorts of advice you can
enroll in programs where they tell you
you're going to do this you're going to
do that you're going to do that you can
be placed into situations where people
have a you know regimented routine
that's supposed to improve you in one
way or another but that doesn't
necessarily work and one of the reasons
why it doesn't necessarily work is
because you can always say I'm not gonna
do your thing I'm gonna do what I want
to do to them you you control whether
you persevere in it or
you don't so when it comes to improving
your own situation at least with respect
to certain Goods you actually have a lot
more control over that than you do in
the effects of your beneficence to other
people particularly when it comes to
moral virtue and intelligence
I can teach students all I want you know
and in every class that I teach some
students get way more out of it than I
ever thought they would
some students totally surprised me
because they started out and I was like
oh this is this person I'm going to do
well and by the end they've you know
through sheer force of effort mastered
the material some students who I thought
we're gonna do a ok turn out you know
because one thing in their life or
another to you know not do well in the
class other students just you know sort
of middle of the road
some students never apply themselves
from the start sometimes never show up
you know those are the ones who you know
they come to class three quarters of the
way where's your textbook I don't have a
textbook how did you figure you're gonna
learn anything I thought you were just
gonna teach me I have some control over
what happens in the classroom but I
don't really have much control over who
does what with what material how much
they get out of it all I can do sort of
prepare the way but if I decide that I
want to learn Mandarin finally you know
hunker down and really learn something
beyond 250 characters and some
conversational stuff that's up to me and
I can I can actually you know by making
the right choices by sticking to those
choices make sure that that happens now
I may not have the greatest aptitude for
that compared to some other people but
if I apply myself there will be some
some improvement in myself and Ross says
when we want to think about
self-improvement we want to think about
these three main entry
do we have a duty to improve our lives
in terms of pleasure this is an
interesting one this is one that that
rasa's they actually sort of following
along with khat to a certain degree and
then deviating from them cotton was
somebody who's very important in Ross is
thinking and Kant's outlook we all have
an inclination to to provide ourselves
with pleasure
anyway we don't really need to work any
harder making our lives more pleasant in
the sense of you know like for instance
I love to eat you know tasty food and I
know how to cook tasty food now I could
say I'm going to take some cooking
classes so I can learn how to make
sausages or learn how to really really
make good omelet or you know I love
pasta dishes maybe I take a cooking
class specifically on that do I have a
duty to improve my cooking abilities so
I can improve my my eating experiences
Ross would say come on now you know you
don't have a duty to improve your
enjoyment of cooking now you know what
about if I took a class where I actually
learn something about the properties of
the ingredients and how they fit in with
the tastes and it's a little bit more
you know science-based in terms of
what's going on with the food Ross would
say yeah okay but now you're talking
about intellectual improvement and not
just having a better time and say the
same thing about a wine tasting class
are you taking the wine tasting class
because you like drinking wine and
rolling it around your tongue and
hanging out with other people who like
to do that and you're like getting you
know getting sloshed because that's what
happens after a while if you swallow you
know even a little bit of it with a lot
of wine tasting what are you actually
learning something about the wine are
you improving your mind and even you're
improving your palate your your
sensitivity your ability to to
differentiate things
Ross would say those are very different
when it comes to improving our
situations with respect to pleasure
Ross would say really you don't have
much of a duty for that now you might
object and say wait a second what about
the kind of people who
characteristically deprive themselves of
pleasure who don't think enough about
that who never really explore anything
and whose lives kind of you know can
suck as a as a result they're they're
unpleasant lives they're lacking in
happiness that they could be enjoying
Ross would say that a person like that
would you know be able to see
self-improvement in terms of of that
that does make sense you know other
another thing that could come up can't
actually brings us up do you have a duty
to pursue your own happiness Khan says
not really except if being miserable
makes you less likely to actually do the
right thing
then yes you you do have a requirement
to to provide yourself with enough
happiness so that you're not going to be
a jerk to people Ansem actually says
something kind of interesting like that
about fasting you know in in the Middle
Ages fasting actually the ancient period
as well fasting was done by many people
who's seen as very important to the
monastic life because you need to get
control over your bodily appetites
before you can even start to work on
your own your screwed-up personality and
Ansem says some people really shouldn't
fast which it's kind of a strange thing
from a guy who did fast a lot and the
long student institution where fasting
is very important and he says here's why
you know some people are able to fast
and they do okay with it and and other
people it just makes them irritable and
if it's going to just make you irritable
better to like not be angry at people
because anger is worse than you know not
having control over your bodily
appetites he thinks better
to be irritable better not to be
irritable and break the fast even though
it be good for you to fast because
you're going to be irritable with
everybody else and that's not good for
you and it's not good for them so that
would be a case
sort of like what Cantus talking about
what Ross is talking about where yes
providing yourself with a certain
modicum of pleasure may allow you to
actually be a better person but there
we're talking about moral virtue in that
case the pleasure is a means not an
intrinsic good but it means to moral
virtue so let's talk now about self
improvement with respect to these other
two intelligence and moral virtue so I
already mentioned that you know I think
Ross would be perfectly fine with saying
that improving your intelligence doesn't
necessarily mean getting yourself a
college degree or even you know some
sort of technical degree in a field
doesn't mean necessarily reading tons
and tons of books or listening to them
on tape it means improving your mind
more more broadly and even in ways that
could connect with the body you know so
taking wine tasting classes and learning
what really goes into a good wine as
opposed to banned wines and how to
distinguish all the different varietals
and some of the history that would be
improving your intellect learning a
foreign language is a way of improving
your intellect doing math problems every
day you know or doing crossword puzzles
those would be ways of improving your
intellect perhaps not as you know
dramatically is is going off and getting
a PhD in something but it but it's
something it's it is improving oneself
or at least holding things at bay
because another thing that we need to
remember too is with intellectual things
although often times we can we can rely
on what we did learn because it's become
habitual it's become part of our
ourselves in a lot of cases it's either
use it or lose it if you don't use it
you're eventually going to lose it and
so we have to fight a kind of
to maintain what we have what about
moral virtue law says we actually have a
duty to make of ourselves better people
than how we have found ourselves and
along with this he doesn't spell this
out would go making sure that we don't
backslide making sure that we don't get
worse making sure that we don't give in
to temptations that we know we shouldn't
get into making sure that we don't take
those kind of steps where you know if
you go to you know those little slippery
slopes you go down this way
you're doing a small gesture but it's
going to start leading to bigger and
bigger things that establish a kind of
moral blindness Ross thinks that you
know we actually do have a duty to
ourselves because we can benefit
ourselves in that way to make ourselves
better people morally so if I have a bad
temper I should work on my temper if I'm
not a generous but a stingy person I
should work on that if I'm at the other
extreme and I'm a spendthrift or a
prodigal and I can't you know I can't
can't keep a dollar from burning a hole
in my pocket as they say I should work
on that
if I tend to take more than my fair
share if I tend to conceal the fact that
I'm taking more than my fair share not
only from other people but myself those
are things that want to you know be
placed front and center for me and I
ought to have some sort of program or
intent at least to make make myself
better in that respect and why should I
do that and partly because it'll make
other people's lives better but but not
just for that reason because I I ought
to be good to myself and to be good to
myself sometimes means depriving myself
of pleasures so that I can become a
better off person in terms of
intelligence or in terms of moral virtue
let's think now about some of the other
things that we might propose as a self
improvement that Ross doesn't talk about
which he probably you know
whatever should have talked about let's
think about bodily health mental health
to a certain extent might overlap with
intelligence and moral virtue even just
certain agree with it you know you're
you know unable to appreciate pleasures
maybe pleasure let's think about bodily
health do you have an obligation to
maintain bodily health Ross I think we'd
be willing to say yes first off you know
instrumentally there's a lot of things
that you're not going to be able to
enjoy in terms of these other intrinsic
goods if you're not bodily healthy
there's a lot of pleasures that you
might be depriving yourself of usually
through indulging yourself in other
pleasures you know it's enjoyable to
exercise once you're actually in shape
getting there of course is kind of
painful and it's laying around and
eating you know eating too many bonbons
or chips or whatever you go on watching
TV that tends to make you fat drinking
too much you know all these sorts of
things portions that are too large but
that deprives you of certain pleasures
lacking bodily health could interfere
with intellectual development and
intellectual pursuits might also
interfere with the ability to develop
moral virtue sometimes these could be
intrinsically connected if one of the
moral virtues has to do with what we
call temperance or moderation of one's
bodily appetites for you know food drink
sex rest all those sorts of things
then indulging yourself to the expense
of health would also be indulging
yourself with you know in relation to
moral virtue but let's put all that it
you know in all that that instrumental
stuff aside do you have a duty to keep
yourself in good health well think about
it in terms of other people if you were
in charge of somebody else wouldn't one
of the things that you want to do with
respect to that person be to me
tain them in a healthy state not
necessarily you know like you know super
athlete but healthy not overweight you
know good Cardo cardiovascular clean
they don't get diseases good immune
system all those sorts of things is that
it is that important I think most people
would say yeah you know if you're
responsible for somebody you probably
should make sure that they're they're
eating right that they're getting
exercise well what about you that you're
in charge of yourself you have a
responsibility to yourself
Ross would say to maintain health what
about making a ton of money
Ross would say now there's there's no
intrinsic requirement that you make
yourself a ton of money money is just an
instrumental good anyway what about
making sure that you're not destitute
what about making sure that you actually
have valuable skills that another person
might pay for so that you could have
these other things and so you're not a
burden on other people I think Ross
would be receptive to saying that say
job training could you know in order to
attain wealth could in fact be self
improvement you'd probably tie that in
with moral virtue and intelligence as
well um contacts your network of
contacts should you be on LinkedIn if
you're an academic should you be on
academia.edu should you have business
cards are those elements a
self-improvement that's a possibility
you can think of other people as well
sometimes it's difficult to maintain
connections particularly if you move I
know this firsthand with friends and
family if you have them is there an
obligation to yourself to maintain those
those contacts maintain those support
networks as something good for yourself
that's plausible
what about opportunities
do you have a duty to seek out
opportunities for yourself or is that
something ancillary something that isn't
really a duty but it'd be nice if you
had it I think Ross would say that
probably depends on the situation a lot
of these are fairly situational but Ross
does think that you do every single one
of us have a duty to ourselves not other
people to ourselves of self-improvement
and that it stems from the fact that we
are somebody each one of us valuable not
just other people but intrinsically as a
person for ourselves